é uma grande escritora norte-americana
chamada Bell hooks tem uma frase um de
seus livros chamado raça representação
que ela disse que a única forma de
auto-recuperação política é a gente
contar nossas próprias histórias e assim
eu fico essa frase fazer muito sentido
para minha vida e para mim a trajetória
mas que quando a gente falava sobre
emergência climática quando a gente
falava sobre as mudanças climáticas
pouco a gente é oportunidade com taças
próprias histórias de falar sobre nossos
territórios de falar sobre as favelas as
periferias e Os territórios mais
afastados nosso país sendo que seus
territórios que mais tem dificuldade que
são os territórios que mais são
vulneráveis a situação da emergência
climática que a gente vive hoje eu sou
Marcelo tenho 23 anos e na cidade nasce
na cidade de Mauá que fica na região do
ABC Paulista aqui uma cidade onde a
gente tem a nascente do rio Tamanduateí
a frente do Rio Tietê mas que a gente
pensa muito pouco ainda sobre a questão
climática e principalmente sobre como
ela nos afeta por ter uma dificuldade de
conseguir saber sobre esse tema e de
conseguir expandir a nossa fala e
expande as nossas vozes nesse lugar
depois de um tempo eu comecei a buscar
aprender mais sobre mudanças climáticas
entendeu estava acontecendo nosso mundo
entende que todas as vezes que falavam
sobre favelas e mudanças climáticas
sempre eram no lugar de culpabilizar AS
periferias e não no lugar de entender as
periferias enquanto parte dessa solução
não de entender a população preta como
parte muito importante desse desse dessa
memória com parte muito importante dessa
história que a gente foi construindo e
também das consequências que acontecem
Através disso assim eu comecei a
pesquisar mudanças climáticas e comecei
a me juntar com jovens do mundo inteiro
que as sextas-feiras se reúnem para
fazer greve uma greve pelo clima uma
greve para ter mudanças reais a nossa
é uma greve que possa nos contribuir
para que a gente possa se manter vivo
porque a gente tá falando sobre a
humanidade falar sobre a emergência
climática é falar sobre o direito a ter
um futuro é falar sobre o direito à
poder pensar as próprias vidas é falar
sobre aqueles que mais sofrem as favelas
ela sempre são alocados lugares como
culpados por isso que a gente tem vivido
culpados por essa vigência climática por
ter casa nas encostas por morar em áreas
de Mananciais mas a favela não é culpada
ela faz parte de uma solução ela faz
parte de uma mudança efetiva para a
sociedade qual a população periférica
ela não foi mais ninguém vai morar na
favela porque quer ninguém mora na
periferia porque quer a gente foi jogado
lá o Brasil é um dos países que mais
escravizou pessoas vindas de África o
Brasil é um dos países que só teve uma
abolição ou melhor uma falsa Abolição
agora no final do século 19 muito
recente
e as suas não tiveram direito as suas
terras as suas não tiveram direito as
suas casas e isso é um mau da
colonização e deu para gente falar sobre
favelas e mudanças climáticas a gente
tem que pensar uma decolonialidad um
pensamento decolonial pois o pensamento
Colonial ele vai falar que a gente tem
que estourar e extrair sem pensar nas
consequências sem pensar no futuro e a
gente começou estou muito tempo nosso
país a nossa nação e o nosso mundo foi
fundado por várias pessoas que pensaram
apenas em explorar os nossos povos
originarios e explorar a população preta
e explorar a natureza sem pensar nas
consequências que isso é um casal para o
futuro sem pensar nas consequências que
são causar para nós que moramos nas
periferias sem pensar nas consequências
que afetam as pessoas negras negras Pois
quando a gente fala que vidas negras
importam a gente fala que não é só a
vida que importa Mas como ela é vivida e
do caminho que a gente tem feito a gente
tem caminhada por uma vida a gente não
consegue
e hoje as nossas casas é são levados
pela enchente onde as nossas vidas são
totalmente perdidas por causa da
qualidade do nosso do nosso respirar e
da nossa vida então a gente tem que
buscar uma mudança efetiva uma mudança
que passe por esse princípio de pensar
toda a comunidade de pensar as soluções
climáticas que pensem as pessoas por
completo não tem como a gente pensar
mudanças climáticas se a gente pensar o
cotidiano todos de uma sociedade as
favelas e as pessoas não são apenas
produtos ou cidades dormitórios no
bairro dormitórios elas fazem parte de
uma sociedade porque elas são as que
mais sofrem as consequências das
mudanças climáticas quando a gente pensa
o Brasil a periferia do Brasil Nordeste
e hoje o nordeste brasileiro é o mais
suscetível até as consequências do
aquecimento global com a alta do mar em
cidades como Recife que pode sumir e
pode desaparecer em poucos anos pensando
tudo que a gente tem vivido Esse aumento
do aqui
bom então precisamos pensar uma cidade
mais sustentável que pense junto com a
juventude que pense para as vidas negras
que pensa em quase dessa veladas que
pense o racismo climático e racismo
ambiental como um eixo que guia essa
transformação da sociedade com eixo que
possa transformar e não apenas ser
descartada dessas políticas públicas Eu
acredito que a gente tem que buscar uma
mudança efetiva e essa mudança é agora
não temos um outro planeta que possamos
nos juntar ao mundo inteiro que têm
buscado aí milhares de jovens têm
buscado a transformação nosso planeta
hoje não há mais tempo a gente tá
literalmente numa contagem regressiva
para o fim não do mundo mais de uma
humanidade Então a gente tem a
oportunidade de lutar hoje porque as
vidas negras importam mas importam como
elas vivem também as vidas periféricas
importam mais importam como esse dia a
dia dela se faz se ela consegue respirar
se ela consegue ter uma qualidade de
vida se ela consegue ter um bom trabalho
e consegue viver com uma Justiça
ambiental Muito obrigado
[Aplausos]